- What up, YouTube, Facebook,
or wherever the hell
you're watching this video.
You're about to watch a
very interesting piece
of content in my opinion.
I'm trying to be better.
I'm trying to give you more value.
This is an incredibly
insightful piece of content
that we've recorded that
we don't normally show.
Which is a complete under the hood
of us analyzing our strategies,
coming up with new ones.
This is a breakdown of how we're thinking
about going forward with our content.
There's no greater thing, no
greater gift I can give you
than to show you the strategy,
strategies where I win.
This is the strategy, the meetings,
the kind of meetings
that get us to the places
that deliver some of the
best business results
in content today.
I care about the content
and the content distribution strategy.
All that shit will work itself out.
If our messenger bot strategy's right,
if we get back to getting our BSU, like,
strategy right, if we actually have a,
you know, YouTube and Snapchat, like,
all that shit works out.
It's how we got here in the first place.
You know, like, thank you so much.
It's very easy to get
- Just making sure.
No more, no more dinner?
- No, no.
I'm just gonna-
thank you so much.
I know the kitchen's closing soon.
To me, that's, we don't have, like,
we can't be this far along and be less,
we're less effective on
YouTube and Instagram
than we were six months ago.
That's just not smart.
- [Commenter] I disagree
with Instagram, YouTube.
- Give me your two cents
on the Instagram part.
- [Commenter] Why,
like, why are you saying
we're less effective?
- My point of view, while
we get to jam on this,
is that my ability over
the last three months,
not predicate on being busy,
to post four times a day
has completely predicated
on my personal subjective
point of view on what content will work
and because I'm so in my shit,
and I'm not, like, Splenda,
my being right is so high, like,
I'm even, like, trying
to post a little bit more
and, like, literally,
watching these posts get,
like, 30,000 or this or that.
Like, I can just feel it.
I can feel it in my soul.
I just wanna post four times a day,
and I wanna get into a
better approving my quotes
or, you know, like, we're just not getting
stuff, like.
- [Commenter] The reason why I'm happy
about it is so we did
this thing, heavy hitters.
Breaking the team into three groups,
four or five people in each group,
and that everybody
decides on the five quotes
that they wanna send you.
And, collectively,
everyone has, basically,
agreed that they think
that's the best version
of how we're gonna make the
best content for the audience.
- That's great.
- [Commenter] In parallel with that,
I think us, like, you
doing that one for that.
There's a lot of versions.
I'll say 80% of anything
we do in that vein,
we have to get your two cents on.
Hey, we wanna do this,
what's your take on it?
Do you wanna do that?
Like, Employee and I want
our versions of those,
was that, like, the fitness meme one.
If there's a picture of you in 2013.
- That's really cool.
- [Guest] But would you post that?
- Probably not, that's
why I'm sitting on it.
Because I think the thing that
we have to use those for Team GaryVee,
the thing that I'm struggling with.
100%.
The thing that I struggle
with is I don't like,
you guys are you and I'm me, meaning,
I get why you guys do
it because it's not you.
I wouldn't do it because
it's too self-serving.
Like even the fitness one, I'm like, hmm.
What am I doing here?
I'm bragging that I got into shape?
I'll always go into
that, what I've noticed,
a subtle thing for tonight is like,
and it's not that you're
doing anything wrong,
it's because you're Employee and I'm Gary,
but I'm posting as Gary for Gary and so,
yeah I've seen that theme a lot.
That's come through a lot of,
even when we were in our best zone.
- [Employee] I've
learned the most is when,
I'll just take a step back
because I know everything
we're making and then
I'll just be like, wait,
and I look at your
profile, and I'm like, oh.
And I'm just getting a feel
for what you're actually
posting versus not.
- I just don't like creating so much
that doesn't get posted.
That just makes no fucking sense.
If you're posting it on
Team GaryVee, I'm thrilled.
- [Employee] That's why if we have buy-in,
if there's five people on the team
who are saying these are the
five things that we can make
I think, if you don't
post it, we're thrilled
because that means Team
GaryVee should be awesome.
- That's fine, so do it.
- [Employee] In parallel, I really like
what we're trying to get to,
it's only like two or three days in,
of sending you five quotes every morning.
- Love it.
- [Employee] Two of them have to be
from the past three days,
the other three should be.
- Classics, whatever.
- [Employee] Classics or
from people in the comments.
- I understand.
- [Employee] So that's generally why.
(mumbling)
- That's great.
- [Employee] Something
that I was thinking,
I was gonna text you guys, but.
Friday, looked at the
light-skinned black gay girl
you met with for like two minutes.
- Yes, she was awesome.
- [Employee] When I was
talking with her after,
I was like, damn, there's
no reason she shouldn't
have been in ABV for like two minutes
telling her story of like why
she started starting a blog.
- That's cool.
So much we can do, I
think Babbin and I today
really did something smart,
this whole notion of.
It's just right, it's where I'm my best,
it's what this all started
with is Ask GaryVee.
- [Guest] Yeah but those
are just moments in time.
We've done that in the past.
- I'm thrilled to, like I love Q&A.
Like I'll do it in my car, I know myself,
like to your point maybe
it's been brought up here and there,
but I fuckin love Q&A, it's
where I show my strength,
- [Guest] It's where
you're your best, yeah.
- [Employee] There will
be more of it, too,
because we're sitting on
3,000 4,000 people we still have to hit up
to try and do the CRM,
and a fourth of them
are going to follow up with,
hey, what does Gary think about barrel,
hey what does Gary think about x y z,
that can be, you know.
- Like the sneaker should now get like,
we should definitely do something
very smart with my website
where the sneakers at the top with like,
you know, it's really
funny to watch things,
like stuff that I'm doing,
my podcast is in the fifties to seventies
when it's my default URL on Instagram,
it's 100 when it's not.
It's real, like it takes a
lot to move up 30 40 spots.
DailyVee was pumping
when I changed the URL
and put a post that pushed to that.
So I think, this is why
I want to go back to
being thoughtful about
the mix of this team here.
The content and the first part,
like the technology, first party CRM data,
our message bot or things of that nature.
First in line is now this
thing that we definitely
know is like really powerful.
Couple things.
- [Employee] Those comments are real, too.
- Well that's why today
was super important,
because first in line needs to
be jab, jab, jab right hook,
and we're right hook,
right hook, right hook,
like we have to.
- [Employee] There's a
pizza company in Hawaii
that wants to give away 3,000 pizzas.
- That is exciting to me.
- [Employee] There's only
fifty people in Hawaii
that are on first in line.
- It's just exciting to be like,
yo, here's 3,000 pizzas.
It's a frozen pizza thing
and they'll ship it?
- [Employee] No, that's why I'm saying
they have to be in Hawaii, this is like a.
- But, this is our chance
to run ads in Hawaii
for like entrepreneurs.
- [Employee] There's a tanning
salon that's giving away
free, there's a gym that's
gonna give away gym memberships,
there's a lot of local stuff,
and then there's also like
a beer koozie.
- You know, for example,
here's what's interesting about Twitter.
What Wendy's does well,
my ability to hack culture is super good.
I'm too busy.
So I need somebody to be trained in like,
not the trending hashtag,
but like what's going on right now today,
and everything that's light weight,
and so much is political.
- [Employee] Crowd
Tangle is so interesting.
- [Gary] Crowd Tangle.
- I think it can be really interesting.
It's what Facebook, it's an app
that Facebook bought
that sources basically
what's trending and
popping and what's popular
on Twitter, Facebook, and Instagram.
So, for example,
we can know what the most
top posts on Instagram are
in the last 24 hours.
- [Gary] So what, explain, do we have it,
do we have to pay for it?
We have it.
- [Employee] It's through
Facebook, we have it.
I sent you an example of
like, these are the top three
Instagram posts like you
can comment on if you want.
- [Gary] I would do that every day,
I would do that right now.
I did it the other day
and it really worked.
Like Boyd lost his mind,
I went to Jay Balbin's
Instagram, I basically was
trying to follow more people,
by the way, real quick,
I'm thinking about unfollowing everybody,
and following one person a day,
like basically what the
Game did with me today,
which is what I pitched them to do for me.
You remember.
What a hack it would
be, if I followed a new
one person every single day,
everybody would come
everyday to see who it is.
It would be like a thing.
It's the ultimate cosign,
and it would become like a thing.
(laughing)
You're like cool.
- [Guest] Are you okay
that Dustin, like yep
the episode goes up in 12,
we go home length and title,
I think we, like, the
9AM post on your Twitter,
but it's the title and the year.
- Yeah, I'm okay with that.
- [Guest] I think that would help.
- That's not enough.
- [Employee] Yeah, I definitely
feel like we could do.
- I'll be honest with
you, I don't need DailyVee
to get any more views
for the rest of my life
and it's a huge win.
I'm documenting.
You have to understand
we have 87 million views
on a video, sitting right now.
The thing that I said hasn't happened yet.
Like when Target gets bought by Facebook,
I'm gonna have a video
get three million views.
Because I'm gonna recall,
to me, DailyVee's about the recall,
not about the views today.
- [Employee] I think we can definitely
get you better creative for Twitter.
We've gotta figure that out,
because for Twitter, to.
- To me, Twitter's about
community management.
Telling you.
There's so much to be done,
surprise and delight,
community management,
hacking the current trends,
making jokes about what's
happening in real life.
You know, to me, it's like.
To me, you know what Twitter's about?
Twitter's about, somebody, Seth being on
with Javi being on his way
down to Philadelphia right now
and giving Meek Mill 1,000 roses.
What I'm, that's what I'm really good at.
Rookie NBA player drops
61, like Booker last year,
dropped like 1,070 points,
we look into him, find out
his favorite video game
is PaperBoy, we buy 70 Paper Boys on eBay,
and we send them to him, and then film it.
Taylor Swift, thank you economy.
That's what I'm really good at.
And it becomes like I'm Santa Claus.
It comes natural to me, I like doing it.
- [Male] So in a world
of that, and us saying,
how do we?
- Easy, we reform our team.
- Well and that's what, we
haven't gotten there yet,
but so we're literally doing
like hashtag first in line
quote on Twitter, our people
tweeting the sub that they want
to see you post or make and
they think is a good quote,
if you actually post it, they get a prize.
The same thing is happening
on YouTube comments,
two people at once.
- Instagram, Instagram live
with another famous person
is a very good idea.
That is, that's the real way
to scale Sophie and Justin,
you know.
People freaked for when
we did this on the plane,
people freaked when we did this at brunch,
like this, what we're filming right now
is the metamoment of it all.
This is the best content we make.
How we make the sausage is
what they fucking care about.
Like these debates and like, all of it.
Q&A, too.
I really think the combination of DailyVee
and the Ask GaryVee show
is the right answer.
Because, if you think about it,
if every vlog has four
questions asked during the day,
one, I'm easy, right?
Like I know myself, I know what I like,
I know what I don't like.
I like Q&A, thus I won't be like fuck you,
like, when you're like,
here, do Instagram.
But questions I just like to answer.
In general I just know they're good.
- There's some crazy, like,
thinking about media now,
shoutouts are just great, like,
for the three that I ran
and now Cena joining them,
it's either, the highest
was six cents a follow.
Down to one cent.
- For what, for me?
Yeah dude, honestly I'm
so frustrated that we're
getting stupider, not smarter.
- No, but I'm saying, now we're about to.
- Flip back.
- Yeah, that's it.
- Yeah, but out of, out of a random moment
when I remembered I'm like yo
can we retalk about this again
which is fine, I mean, I love like I'm not
I'm not mad about it.
I'm just laughing, I'm
not even like being like
you should've done
that, I'm just laughing.
- [Employee] We have a paid meeting that,
we wanted the black and white version,
of like the best version of running ads,
and it's actually can
you make the best content
and send it in Kick to a 16-year-old?
- So fuckin' Mazel Tov.
- [Employee] No, I know, but
that's why we got fucked up.
- I don't think so, because I do think,
I think both matter.
It's just having the right allocation.
- [Employee] Well the
real question is like,
cool, if we have our budget,
where are we valuing?
- I couldn't agree more.
The good news is by doing
all of that, we have context.
Instead of guessing.
So, for example, no I got a good one.
So, if I'm going to Philly and
I'm not doing the dinner now
because it's not working,
why don't I do a secret meet-up.
Scavenger hunt and just like fuckin
just fucking hang out for
an hour with 100 people.
- [Employee] Good amount of
data on a 55K first in line.
- What do you mean?
We can do stuff, you mean?
- Yeah, I mean like,
just from an IG bio alone,
we can learn shit about them.
In terms of just like.
- We have to find an internet company,
we have to give a $25 gift card
to everybody on their birthday,
from some sort of like
gifts.com or like, we
have to find somebody
who's like into that.
It's just nice.
- [Employee] I mean people fucking love
just the happy birthday.
- Agree, people like 50 bucks even more.
- [Employee] Then it becomes, then people.
- I wanna, honestly, we need to,
we need to really give some thought,
I think maybe Justin we should train him,
it will take him a while,
I have to do what I used to do, oh god,
when somebody was like, when I was like,
when I did, like Bannon at thebill.org
told a story from nine years ago,
you were there with me?
Like literally I tweeted once,
I have to learn how to say no,
and some guy tweets at me
he goes, I'll teach you,
send me 100 bucks, and
I sent him 100 bucks,
and then, two fifties, and
then he came to south buy
and found me and wanted to give it back,
but then I only took 50 of it back.
(mumbling)
There's something that I
feel like we should be doing.
- I'm gonna tweet it right now.
I'm gonna tweet, what fun
thing can I do for you?
Love that shit.
- [Employee] You want to
like, give them wine, or,
the cheap, the fuck
fear tees or something.
- Remember I sent that
dude a burger in Wyoming,
like that's the shit.
- [Employee] That's the
shit that I responded to.
You tweeted what can I do for you today,
and then I saw the dude send him a burger.
- [Guest] I think India's
first day working with you
she had to get coffee for like 700 people
all around the country.
It was like iced coffee.
- I want to do something
so crazy at the NFL draft.
(side conversing)
The big thing is we're filming everyday
and we're
we're not playing it
right, I really sense it.
Even like, Babbin when you're like,
can you do this?
And I'm like, and I always, like.
- [Babbin] I just like,
weirdly don't even think
you should film,
especially right now
because you're so deep
in Mayer media, like Tyler and
I are looking at the schedule
and I'm like, I know nothing
is going to happen today,
I just think it would be more useful
of our time on those days.
- I'm cool with that.
I'm cool with that.
I feel like I've gotten there.
We nailed the vlog, we do keynotes,
we like nailed it, it's like
the GaryVee audio experience.
I want to document as much as possible,
it's cool, I was in Boston today.
Look, I do think the
Q&A changes everything.
Like, I'll tell you this,
I like Q&A, and like,
one out of every two times, I think,
as I'm walking in between
one meeting to the four Ds,
I'll answer one fucking question.
It's, I like it.
I like it different than
like, make a SnapChat video,
and be like, I like, I like it.
- [Guest] Every single
influencer that comes in,
we should literally make them
ask you a question on camera
and then you respond.
- 100,000% that's right.
That's right.
By the way, we don't need them to come in.
Have every single one of these influencers
on the 5,000 B list send
in a video question,
I'll answer it, that's
the two minute video,
and target their fans.
You want a good idea?
That.
You know where we're not even close?
The Hassan Minhaj and me clip
of the Houston Rockets and Cavs fan
clipped properly, right now,
while Houston and the Cavs
are in the playoffs, is just not smart.
It's like so good.
- [Employee] I think we generally
exploit a lot of our shit.
- Well we just can't help
it, there's so much volume.
- [Guest] I think that clip specifically,
and this is why I like that kid Dustin,
I don't think that's in the
vein of D Rock or Babbin, really
in terms of their skillset
and how they see content
and the content that
they want to be making.
They want to be swaggy and
artists and all that shit.
I think the person that
would crush that 60-second
version of Hassan Minhaj
is someone who does
like epic viral fails,
you know what I mean?
- I'm thrilled.
(crosstalking)
- I mean, I think you guys
should definitely do it,
but you're not like.
- It's not default.
Whereas somebody else who
is a 15-year-old kid now,
that was their early craft.
It's not what you were influenced by.
I think Twitter's interesting.
Twitter's interesting for
me because it's native,
I'm in it all the time.
I reply to more people
tweeting about the text
about happy birthday
than I ever do in anything
in the text, you know?
- [Male] Especially culture right now,
culture is twitter.
The discussion lives on Twitter.
- By the way, it always has.
Even when Twitter was in its lull,
there is no social network.
There's no place.
Twitter's the water cooler.
But Twitter's the place
where I can do so much
because like, for example,
Twitter's the place where I can like,
people, people, I'm always
taking the high road.
Anytime I even show any level of rebuttal,
people go crazy.
Like crazy, they're like so happy,
they're like finally, get him.
Bless you.
Like throwing shade at stuff, or like,
and especially as my profile
is getting bigger now,
I was never at a place
where I was actually like,
like I can definitely now
engage with a celebrity
and have something happen.
Again, any celebrity on
Twitter says I'm hungry,
like sending them a burger is better,
we will kill that shit.
- [Employee] We need to do a
cross-analysis, too, of who's.
- You become a caricature
of yourself, it's forever.
You know?
That's why I like the Q&A in DailyVee,
it brings real value, it
brings two things I'm good at.
It's why like, a DailyVee needs
to just literally be like,
here's where you guys can
get a little more creative.
So let's talk about this.
I literally go like 2
for 31 from the field,
like I played terrible
the other day, right?
I wonder if that DailyVee
needs to show every one
of my shots that I missed,
and then how do we
manifest, which is not easy,
how do we manifest me talking about like,
the fact that business is like that, too,
like you can lose, you can
literally miss 31 shots
but if you make one, like
why do I keep shooting?
- [Guest] Well in your
tweet, that you tweeted out.
- Which one?
- You talked about, like, you know,
something about shots and missing.
You don't miss any shots you don't take,
something like that.
- Yeah I mean, that's
like a classic saying,
that's not mine, but like,
just the notion of like,
the mindset of like, they're my Ls.
Like, cool, you can critique.
- [Employee] You'd be better
off going 1 for 15, than.
- O for 0.
We should do way more
engagement and whiteboard stuff.
I need to film something tomorrow
where my hand goes even lower,
that post was, that was unbelievable.
You know what was great about that post?
I'll admit it, not that it was luck,
I'm so grateful that I went
with the tagging thing.
It was the right post to do that callback.
That created absurdity.
- [Female] That's what made it.
- What made it, like, it worked together.
The visual is amazing.
- [Waiter] Anything else
I can get for you, man?
- Great, thank you.
The visual is fucking crazy, like,
it looks like I'm coming
out of an Instagram post.
It's really cool.
You know what would be really cool?
Could I do this and basically
it seems like I'm talking,
wait a minute, how is it set up,
yeah, can I basically reference
the next photo in your stream?
- [Guest] Pointing to the previous post
would be easier I think.
- That'd be really cool,
if like, everyone has
like a different experience.
- [Guest] Like caption
the photo above this.
- [Employee] That's a
big thing on Twitter.
That's a little bit like
the, when you do two photos
next to each other.
(crosstalking)
- Let's look at it right, here I am,
how do you do?
- [Female] So, the reason
it works really well
from the bottom is because
we're faking the bottom.
And we can fake the top
but it's not going to look as cool.
- It's not going to look as cool.
- [Female] You're not going to see
the interactive space right there.
So I think we should
do what you're saying.
- I could, what about archiving,
that would archive,
nobody gives a fuck right?
- [Guest] That doesn't drive engagement.
It's like a doubletap.
- But I mean, this one does, right,
we're doing the blue arrow,
but like maybe if I really time it
and I'm coming out into,
but again we fake it, right,
so it's not.
- [Employee] Something
we were playing with for
Heavy Hitter was doing something about,
I love when you do like,
call somebody you haven't
spoken to in years,
like, tell someone you love them today,
like even doing a
handwritten message to you,
and it's just a general hey I love you,
haven't talked to you in a while.
And then we did, you pointing to like
the share button, maybe, and it's like
share this with the person that you know
you need to share it with.
- [Guest] The problem with
the share button one right now
is every phone is different
on the sizing of the photo.
- Is that right?
- [Guest] Yeah, so, your photo,
like if you pointed at the
share button on your photo,
it would be different on my phone.
- [Female] We should do
a video of you actually
tapping the buttons,
like basically that still
from our video for a minute,
taps part highlights, where
you tap the share arrow.
- Do you guys see this, I apologize too,
do you see this?
It's got 78,000 likes.
- [Guest] A photo of yourself.
I do think photos of you would work,
I know we sent you a few.
- Photos of me have worked.
And you know what really works, I got it,
but you know what really works
is good photos.
The same thing that
everybody actually does
in Instagram, which is like, really cool,
we should do that.
Man.
This whole notion of
motivation and optimism
as a strategy, not like, some vanilla,
I'm tapping into something.
I haven't fully.
(mumbling)
(video playing on phone)
No, I watched the whole thing.
I'm onto something with it.
I haven't figured it fully fully out,
but it's 100% right.
- [Employee] Colin and I actually,
we're working on the SlideShare.
- Yeah, dude how's it going?
- [Employee] It's better.
Sid was playing with it more from like,
let me talk to you about it as a deck,
and I'm like no it needs
to be an article as a deck.
That's like when we just
press buttons on it,
it all makes sense.
But it should be done
tomorrow or the day after.
Colin made an article off of it,
because you basically open
up that keynote with like
it's the greatest year to be
alive, it's not even a question
and I just don't understand how,
you could look at it any other way,
and by the way, it also helps you
to be looking at things like this.
- It's unbelievable how
many people bring it up.
(mumbling)
It's just so big.
- [Female] We're pushing
it about three times a week
on stories, too.
For Snapchat and Instagram.
- There is times that are overindexing,
like Sunday night is super interesting.
I think if we looked at
our Sunday night data,
Sunday night is super interesting.
- [Employee] Just across social?
Across the world, culture.
- Yeah, if you think about it.
If you think about Sunday
night, historically,
it's like the HBO shows,
like, it's Sunday night.
It's a unique moment.
- [Employee] Social, the general
thing is that it's actually
the noise makes it's hard to be heard.
- I get it.
But I'm at the, if you're
at the top of the sphere
of whatever you are,.
I'll tell you right now, though.
The way the Instagram algorithm
on comments is right now,
I should be commenting on
top people left and right.
It's such a hack.
Like I'm gonna go to Meek Mills' Instagram
right now and win.
(electropop music)